once
Spa Focus what's up everybody today I am
making a cooking video and today I am
gonna be making one of those IG videos
I've been making on my Ig I've been
repeating a lot of words back to back to
back
[Music]
I am making a cooking video but not on
this channel actually because I've been
I've made cooking videos on this channel
but today I am making one for my
Instagram and if you've been following
me on Instagram which is at Shannon
broad or actually follow my new
Instagram at Casey makes food that's
where I've been posting a lot of my
newer cooking content I've been doing a
lot of like Fusion type stuff I don't
know just things that excite me and you
know little ideas that pop up my brain
on my I wonder if that works but uh you
know I'm spending some time with the
family right now Tiff and I have
actually been learning Mandarin and uh
it's been interesting so like Tiff's
always been interested in learning
Chinese uh learning Cantonese because I
speak Cantonese and you know my
Cantonese is it's all right but you know
I've been notoriously known for uh and
Tiff will never let let go of this I
once told her that she should stop
learning Cantonese because Cantonese is
a quote-unquote dying language and that
Mandarin is kind of like the power play
That's The Power language that you
should learn if you're a business person
you know English you know Spanish and
Mandarin Chinese you're set right and so
I've always wanted to learn Mandarin
myself and so we've been dabbling in
learning mandarins I'm gonna throw you a
Cantonese word you say the Mandarin word
for it okay
so nice give me one give me a good one
I'm sick
Lancer how about this one t-saw
yeah how about me
oh that's that's you yep
Fiji about tear
no that one's hard huh it's the tones
but it actually Mandarin's a lot easier
because there's only four tones versus
nine and Cantonese but it's been really
fun learning Mandarin via Cantonese
because I already knew a lot of
Cantonese words and discovering that
they're so similar in Mandarin it just
made it a lot easier to remember that's
actually how we've been learning our
Mandarin lately we have been using Canto
to Mando blueprint to learn our Mandarin
can't do the mandal blueprint is exactly
what it sounds like it is it's a program
that uses a novel copy and paste method
that is specifically designed for
Cantonese speakers to learn Mandarin
raise your hand if you speak Cantonese
and you can't learn Mandarin to save
your life me I'm gonna raise both my
hands because that is I've gone through
so many summer courses trying to learn
Mandarin like throughout my childhood
never picked up any of it just never
could and you know what the problem was
they taught you with English can't turn
Amanda has pointed out an interesting
way of learning Mandarin if you're a
Cantonese speaker because Cantonese is
extremely similar to Mandarin from a
sentence structure standpoint and so if
you know Cantonese and you can learn
Mandarin through a unique Avenue and
what if your Cantonese is completely
broken and you have an accent and you
don't know all the vocabulary words like
me have no fear it still works you can
still learn Mandarin even if you have
broken Cantonese do it if you learned
I've learned my pronouns thus far nice
yeah so all
yeah in Mandarin whoa oh yeah I knew
that yes I was trying to learn Mandarin
how about you yes yes
that's you that's you in Cantonese and
then in Mandarin me
blueprint is made by Kanto Mando and a
team of professional tutors to help
canteen speakers like me and maybe you
maybe to learn conversational mandarins
super super fast you don't even need to
know how to read or write which I never
learned how to read or write I'd like
the squiggly lines for me and as long as
you speak a little bit of Cantonese
you're good interestingly enough
Mandarin only has four tones versus the
six or nine or ten twelve I think nine
nine nine that Cantonese has so
theoretically Mandarin should be easier
that's why I was trying to learn
but I stopped going to my classes
because they were too far you don't have
to worry about this program being too
far away because you can use it from the
comfort of your own home at your own
pace and you get lifetime access to the
program it dawned on me how similar the
languages were when they were able to
stack it Acro on top of each other just
word for word and I've never viewed it
through that lens I've always viewed it
like oh here's the English sentence and
here's the Mandarin sentence but to see
the canteen isn't matter impacting back
Game Changer if you're a Cantonese
speaker that keeps putting off learning
Mandarin like me check out the Canto the
Mando blueprint and a link below to
start speaking conversationally fluent
Mandarin today all right on to our
mystery dish for the day now previously
I've been making uh I've made a fried
Hainan chicken sandwich on The Toasted
brioche bun add the ginger scallion
sauce then place the cucumbers on as if
you would pickles add your Fried Chicken
slice of the chili sauce on top and top
with the bun there you have it fried
Hainan chicken sandwich I've made a mapo
meatball sub which is actually really
tasty next prep your baguette and lay
meatballs on the bread add some
provolone cheese on top and if you want
top it off with some more sauce sprinkle
on some green onions and there you have
it mapo meatball sub the last one I did
was a peking duck Carnitas Taco to
assemble our Taco load up a tortilla
with a generous amount of duck spoon
some cucumber Pico on top and top it off
with some Cotija cheese and there you
have it duck Carnitas taco and actually
that was actually by far my favorite one
so today we are making something that I
think might be the most outlandish idea
that I've come up with and I'm not quite
sure if it's even gonna work I have a
feeling this might be the first dish I
make that might come out like poo poo
but we're gonna try it anyways because
that's the whole point of a test kitchen
even through failures I'm gonna post it
whatever and uh I'm gonna eat it and
we'll see if I like it so today we are
making curry cheese fries AKA swap out
the chili put in some Curry Beef we'll
see how it goes all right so I've got my
set set up I got a two light system a
top down camera and we got a profile
I'll shot over there all right so since
we are making curry cheese fries we're
gonna need some potatoes cut them into
Fry's shapes I guess you know what
actually this is the first time I've
ever made fries from scratch I don't
think I've ever made fried from scratch
you would think it's so simple so simple
that I would have done it already by now
I'm actually not deep frying my fries
today I'm going to be air frying my
fries so it's a little healthier let's
try to make fries together
[Music]
cut the potatoes to the best of my
abilities into French fry shapes and
some of these are kind of not uniform in
fact most of them are not uniform so
we'll see how they turn out
[Music]
okay so it's starting to smell really
good in here the curry is turning off
fantastic better than I was expecting
actually because uh this is basically a
chili recipe that I've converted into
Curry you got the coconut milk that is
just creating an amazing Aroma all right
so now we are gonna make our cheese
sauce for this curry cheese fries and
cheese is a interesting component to
Asian food because Asian Foods typically
don't have cheeses although like Korean
cuisine you do see some cheese Japanese
Cuisine has definitely integrated cheese
into their Foods Indian food
traditionally actually has some cheese
as well so you know it could work but
yeah so we're gonna do a cheese sauce
that's gonna be cheddar based just like
how chili cheese is supposed to be like
but instead of cream we're gonna use
coconut milk and we're gonna see how
that is gonna mix with cheddar cheese
I don't know about you but I'm excited
about this project smells fantastic
can't wait to finish
all right so the cheese sauce is done
now it looks apart but it kind of has a
funky smell
I don't know we'll see we'll taste it I
don't know
[Music]
we have uh created french fries they
look the part
but do they taste the pot
it could be crispier
in fact they're not crispy at all okay
next time we are definitely frying our
french fries another reason why we're
not gonna be air frying anymore it takes
forever to air fry like I can't fry more
than like two french fries at a time
that's more than that but like you get
the point like gone through five batches
now and all I've got is this much French
fries
all right I am done filming my video and
um
I just took a bite could be because I
was the one I made it but I don't know a
little underwhelmed but um me Familia is
here they have been smelling it smells
fantastic in here it's really good
all right dig in curry cheese fries
go for it
[Music]
weird
did you make the fries from scratch too
yeah
[Music]
and you expected to have more flavor huh
yeah it's not it's very aromatic but not
a lot of like spicy like spices or like
Flavor yeah I think you need salt yeah
maybe I just need to add more salt or
something but like it smells a certain
way and you'd expect it to taste the way
it smells but it's not bad though right
underwhelm
ing not as overwhelming
[Laughter]
it's just whelming I'm not bad but yeah
I think like if I would buy this I'd be
like oh it's over hyped or whatever
that's just the curry by itself maybe
it's the curry I need to work on how
come you decided to add beans Curry's
good good uh added beans because uh well
that's what chili has hey I'm really
surprised you guys are like digging in
well I'm glad you guys like the
appetizer and for dinner we have pizza
what's funny is uh when I do these
videos I take the entire kitchen hostage
like it is a live set and so like not
just the kitchen practically the whole
house because we all have to be like
super quiet
music true true yeah it needs more salt
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
got my braces done oh yeah look at that
I know I've been wanting to post about
you starting High School taking your
braces off but he doesn't let me post
anything it's actually really surprising
he's allowed us that's so untrue for the
vacations every time we're like
okay is that all right do we have your
permission I get it though there's some
days where I don't want to Vlog either
and I'm like I just don't want to be on
camera so I get it but but since I'm the
one vlogging every time I'm Vlogging I
am ready to Vlog let's just finish it
sweet glad you're my number one fan
[Music]